simone bile's decision is intensifying a
new conversation about
mental health and sports especially on
the world stage
three-time olympic gymnast dominique
dawes knows what it's like to be
in the spotlight she helped the u.s win
its first gold medal
in the women's gymnastics team final
back in 1996.
the team of seven earned the nickname
the magnificent seven
dominique dawes joins us now good
morning so good to see you
and you know you had to face your own
obstacles
at that time you're the first
african-american individual medal winner
in artistic gymnastics
you have to in some ways i'm guessing
relate to what simone biles is going
through were you shocked
by this news that she pulled out of
these events so far
i can certainly relate wholeheartedly i
remember stepping out into the georgia
dome before the 1996 olympic games
and prior to doing that having an
emotional breakdown just feeling
all the pressure that uh team usa felt
from needing to make history so
when i awoke the other day to hear that
simone biles had pulled out of the
competition i did not think it was for
mental issues i thought it was possibly
because of an injury
then when i heard it was a decision that
she made after going through a certain
vault and having a mental block i could
again relate to that because i went
through a lot of mental blocks
i commended her for listening to her
inner voice
and doing what was best for simone biles
gymnasts are usually in a very
controlled environment we are trained to
be robots we don't listen to our inner
voice it's been muted
and i love the fact that she listened to
herself and she did what was best for
her mental health
as well as to ward off any possible
injury i know dominique what did you
think when you heard her say the other
day she feel
she felt the whole weight of the world
on her shoulders
my heart just went out to her knowing
that she was feeling
such tremendous pressure yes the sport
of gymnastics is filled with a great
deal of anxiety a great deal of fear a
great deal of intimidation
and a great deal of pressure and for her
being known as the goat the greatest of
all time
having a goat on your lead guitar doing
an interview with the goat i was like
that's a little much and very ballsy
however
i felt as if you know what she can
overcome whatever pressure there is but
she's human she's going to feel she's
going to hurt she's going to be wounded
and now as a mother of four and now even
standing in my own gymnastics gym here
in maryland
so dominique dawes gymnastics academy
it's all about creating a very healthy
and encouraging environment one in which
that's not filled with pressure
boy dominique the mother of four just
think about let us take that in for a
second standing in your own
gymnasium go you do you think the the
the effect of not having family and
friends in the stands
what role that must play because i would
think that that's she said it's the
first time that she's ever done it
without them and she's used to looking
at
looking up at them yes her support
system is so important it's important
for everyone
i love the fact that she leans on her
catholic faith but her mom and dad are
also so very important and her sister
and as you can see online
she actually has a boyfriend she has
friends the young girls on this team
they actually seem like they get along
and they support one another you need
that
atmosphere of your family and your
friends and your fans right there in the
in the stands there cheering you on they
add to the pressure i will say that
however that's something that is a
comfort if you're used to seeing them
there
dominique we also saw naomi osaka
withdraw from some tennis events
recently do you think this is uh this is
a turning point for athletes in
in looking after their mental health
more and being vocal about it i
really think this is from the dialogue
that was created from the metoo movement
and then when everything came out in
2016 with regards to the scandal of
larry nassar the olympic team doctor
who sexually abused hundreds of young
women now we're speaking about the
unhealthy culture in the sport of
gymnastics
now we're talking about the importance
of mental health as you guys mentioned
earlier michael phelps's
piece on hbo talking about his
depression things of that nature this is
a wonderful platform for athletes to now
express what they've been experiencing
with regards to anxiety with regards to
depression with regards to pressure and
i love that these athletes are listening
to their inner voice and doing what's
best for them
and dominique to that point about larry
nassar how much of an impact do you
think
that plays on simone bile's psyche
because this was an
organization that she felt didn't do
enough and here she is
on that stage for that organization that
she feels didn't protect her and other
athletes
yes i admire simone biles more for her
speaking out and speaking her truth than
her amazing athletic prounish what she
does out there
i am so thankful i'm retired she is
generations above her competition
but the fact that she's on the floor and
she's even said this as the only
survivor competing on the floor
she felt as if usa gymnastics would
brush all the unhealthy aspects of this
culture under the rug
if she were not out there the fact that
she said that and she was still
competing under usa
gymnastics that to me was quite
courageous
and the fact that she had to endure that
um shows how strong she is
yeah she's been courageous in so many
ways dominique dawes thank you so much
for being with us this morning